[Music]
you are watching The Press preview first
look at what's on the front pages as
they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with a journalist
and broadcaster Jenny cleeman and the
former conservative MP and advisor to
the Royal household who's now chief
executive of the charity business in the
community Mary McLeod they'll both be
with us from now until just before
midnight so let us see what is on the
front pages for you well Rob quits in
Fury that's the lead for the guardian
after the Deputy Prime Minister quit
over workplace bullying allegations but
refused to accept he was in fact a bully
the time says Mr Rob went down swinging
in the face of what he says was a
tyranny of subjective hurt feelings
the I meanwhile says the civil servants
who worked under him are angry at what
they call his tone death resignation
the express quotes allies of Mr Rob as
saying he was forced out just for
wanting the best for Britain
the telegraph reports that in the end it
was a row over a plan to put Spanish
forces on the ground in Gibraltar during
brexit negotiations that scuppered Mr
Rob
the male asked if this was the day the
country became ungovernable when a top
cabinet minister was forced to quit for
hurting the feelings of civil servants
the growing troubles at the CBI lead the
financial times with several major
companies quitting the organization
after new allegations of serious
misconduct
and the star returns to an old favorite
the weather
with a prediction of Arctic winds to
come followed by a mini heat wave
confused you will be Now reminder that
by scanning the QR code you'll see on
screen during the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch us
and we are joined tonight by Jenny
cleeman and Mary McLeod welcome to both
of you
um so to the one story in town this
evening Rob quits in Fury that's the
headline on the front of the Guardian
Jenny
yes the guardian says that uh Dominic
Robb quit grudgingly he grudgingly
accepted the findings of the inquiry but
I I don't think that he grudgingly is is
really the right word I mean he was
Furious clearly today his resignation
letter was Furious some of the
television interviews he gave today were
incredibly defiant he showed absolutely
no remorse he doesn't agree with the
findings of the inquiry but he had boxed
himself in because he had of course said
that if he was uh found to have been a
bully at all he would resign and on two
counts uh they were found not in his
favor uh he thinks he's done nothing
wrong which is probably why he should
resign because uh he was found I think
the word abrasive is mentioned sort of
six or seven times in the report he is
found to have been aggressive his whole
take is that he never swore and shouted
you can be a bully without uh swearing
and shouting
um his take he's Come Out Swinging his
take is that uh he has been targeted by
unionized officials
um he says he uh he had been warned that
uh these these civil servants uh were
trying to undermine him basically and
they had ganged up on him to get rid of
him but the thing is if if you uh think
you're being targeted by unionized
officials you can not give them the
ammunition you can uh not behave in such
a way that allegations like this stand
up when there's a thorough investigation
uh into these claims so um bullies often
accuse their victims of being passive
aggressive which is what dominic Robb is
doing here he's saying that civil
servants are being passive aggressive
aggressive and resisting him because
they don't agree uh with the politics of
what he's doing but
one person's definition of passive
aggressive is another person uh behaving
in a certain way because they're
frightened and they uh they don't know
what to do in the face of a very
aggressive minister in order for the
business of government to work
um civil servants need to feel that they
can disagree with ministers and
ministers need to feel that they can
talk to civil servants there needs to be
a proper exchange of ideas clearly this
was not possible in the Departments
where um where Dominic Robb was running
in those cases uh where there were
several allegations of him being a bully
so it's right that he's resigned uh Mary
he's uh described omnic Robb this is
he's described those uh civil servants
as activist civil servants and said that
they were trying to block the work of of
government and they were culture
resistance to there was a cultural
resistance to policies and also that the
threshold for bullying was too low
yes and you know there's there's two
sides to very clearly in the newspaper
day of the two sides to this story
um but it has led to Dominic Robb
resigning given the report findings and
and they do he has apologized in his
letter and for any unintended stress or
offense that officials felt and but he
does put in it that is due to peace
standards and Challenge and that's where
there has to be a really clear
understanding of how you still get
things done in government and be able to
challenge but that is very different to
bullying and intimidation and there's a
48-page report into the behavior by Adam
Tully Casey so this has been looking at
various rules
um of Dominic Robb as a deputy prime
minister just a secretary Lord
Chancellor foreign secretary brexit
secretary and but as Jenny mentioned and
you know Rob did say in an interview
earlier this year that he would resign
of the report found any signs from
acting inappropriately towards officials
and therefore he has kept his word by
resigning and even though the report
cleared him of six charges there were he
did uphold the the other two claims
um and they've said it was an abuse of
power and intimidated staff and but yes
um doming Robert is angry about this and
he doesn't feel that he was bullying he
didn't shout and swayed at staff and but
the the report and it's interesting then
it goes right across whether it's
government business society as a whole
is what is it that constitutes bullying
and and the report basically clearly
lets out of the shows that if it makes
you if you make someone feel
uncomfortable if you belittle them
Target them if you're aggressive
intimidating and then then that counts
as as bullying so those charges were
upheld but there has to be a Way Forward
there are performance issues with civil
servants then there are ways to discuss
that that with them and there needs to
be a clear procedure to complain about
MPS on in this case ministers and Simon
case the cabinet secretary is looking at
how to handle these complaints but this
is you know really about how leaders
um get the best out of their teams
whether I said as business or or in
government and how you need a positive
workplace culture
um which you need that for morale for
well-being for productivity so it's
really critical that any allegations of
bullying or intimidation and are
absolutely investigated and acted upon
swiftly so I think there may be more to
come on on this story but it's one that
is not just for ministers and government
it's about how do leaders write across
um Society work with people make them
feel as though they are are valued
listen to them and yes develop them and
and tell them if things aren't
appropriate and they need to do some
better work but it's done it can be done
in different ways and and this has shown
that a the report has shown that that
Rob had done it and just wasn't
acceptable yes and Jenny speaking to
your um
comment earlier that Dominic Raab has
shown No Remorse in the Sunday the
Saturday time sorry and he's actually
saying that the government risked being
derailed by a tyranny a subjective hurt
feelings I mean that that just his the
tone in his words there
obviously suggests that there is no
remorse
well and it suggests more than that he
is casting himself as a victim of uh
snowflake culture that's what this
tyranny of hurt feelings is and this is
the thing about bullying is there isn't
a standard definition uh it is to do
with how you make people feel this isn't
about hurt feelings though if you look
at the report it's about uh people
feeling uh continually intimidated there
were reports of someone being physically
sick before a meeting with Dominic Robb
this is more than her feelings but he is
casting this as uh he being a doer
working with a bunch of uh frankly
feeble people who um who are he talks
about subjective hurt feelings that stop
ministers delivering for voters and this
is going to play very well into into the
kind of culture War part of politics at
the moment and this idea that um you
know the doers are being scuppered by
these uh incredibly weak feeble people
and their and their hurt feelings but
that would be a misrepresentation of the
allegations and what's in the report you
can give critical feedback back to
people who work for you without making
them physically sick or scared to come
to work I think many people have worked
with someone who is a bully or who is
very unpleasant and knows what it's like
to wake up in the morning and have that
feeling of dread because you're going to
have to interact with them it is not a
necessary requirement of being a strong
leader and good at your job to to be
unnecessarily harsh on people in fact I
think we all know now that that is not a
component of leadership being able to
strike fear Into the Heart of people who
who work with you and what's quite
worrying is that the narrative now is
that this is to do with activist civil
servants trying to manipulate the system
uh by claiming to be hurt by being
snowflakes basically and that's very
worrying because that's not what the
report found and yet when we turn to the
I Mary they're reporting the fact that
the the civil servants are angry at the
tone of the resignation from Dominic
rather the fact that it's it's tone deaf
and didn't display any remorse
whatsoever
it's a law he did actually does say in
that letter that he apologizes for any
unintended stress or events that that he
caused officials and but I think overall
I think the officials are saying he's
he's not really accepting that the the
two well he actually Rob does accept the
report but
um I think the officials are saying that
they don't see any sort of change in in
or what his behavior would be so uh so I
think this is a is a really important
um lesson on on this I think it's
there's been Behavior that's gone on in
business and in in government for for a
long time and that just he wouldn't
really tolerate in another aspects and
certainly when years ago in business
when there's a case of bullying came up
and it was in essence that if someone
felt intimidated
um and bullied therefore they had a case
that there had to be answer to and I
remember then we'd we let go of a senior
um executive because of that so it's you
know these are
um really important I think questions
about how we run workplaces how we make
sure that people can actually do their
best and we get the best out of them
welcome back you are watching The Press
preview and still with me Jenny Clement
and Mary McLeod let's take a look at the
financial times weekend and uh this
story about the CBI that we've been
running in our uh bulletins throughout
the the evening and the big names that
are deciding to um withdraw their
membership after a second woman has
alleged that she was raped while working
for the CBI Mary take us into this
yeah it's been a very difficult few
weeks for the CBI as this story has
unfolded of shocking experiences of
workplace Behavior culture sexual
misconduct allegation of rape sexual
harassment drug taken bullying and of
course Tony danker the director General
and when there were allegations about
his conduct and he was dismissed of
course for for workplace misconduct and
since then horrific to hear that there
are now two separate allegations of rape
they've taken place historically
um at the CBI so yes so many companies
um it has been reported that they've
they're left or suspended their their
membership and does not waste John Lewis
Aviva wpp Virgin Media Tesco Etc Lloyd's
Buster card no longer working with the
CBI for now
um and the CBI have come back and
um they're now suspended all policy and
membership activity until June there
will be an extraordinary general meeting
where where they will the CPI will try
and present a reformed and refocused
um a CBI and showing what that change in
culture will be
um but that you know of course that
independent investigation has taken
place
um at the cbis that requests has led to
the suspension of three staff so the
conclusions will be published
um next week and I and I do wish rain
Newton Smith who's a new director
General
um all the best as she tries to manage
this crisis and also the present of the
CBI Brian McBride
um who need to lead in the organization
through this but it's it's a really
important
um a time for them as they really as
they try and find a way through and to
change what seems to be the culture and
you know certainly I know from business
in the community which is another
business membership organization and a
network of Business Leaders I mean there
has to be Zero Tolerance
um approach to inappropriate behavior
let's just see if we can get Jenny do
you have to show your series because
we're running out of time so they are
pledging cultural reform is that
possible or does the CBI need to be
disbanded Jenny
I think it might be a bit too late for
the CBI it is clearly becoming toxic and
as as an organization that's supposed to
lobby for the interests of business it
needs two things it needs lots of big
businesses to be members and it needs
the era of government and at the moment
it has neither and so you know I would
say it's on very thin ice at the moment
I I can't really think of what it would
take for them to turn things around and
they're taking these measures which
which is great but it does feel like the
CBI is on its its lost legs when it's
when it's hemorrhaging uh members major
companies pulling out minute by minute
today
yes uh married that as we've already
suggested they are in really saying that
the CBI will be closed for business
until this extraordinary meeting when
they'll get members to vote on the
future but with your experience within
the business Community what is their
their next move what can they do
well they're going to do a root and
Branch review of everything listen to
people within the organization and bring
in hopefully experts to help them show
them the way of how you create an
inclusive culture and make sure that
people feel that they're creating a sort
of safe environment for people to to
work in but they they definitely need to
find that way through to how to be more
inclusive how to create that culture
where people feel supported included
safe be able to perform their their best
and you can change culture and and but
it's fundamental reform it's systems
processes education and positive action
so I hope they can do it